are we on overtime overtime we're doing
again first of all thank you for coming
back I know we were kind of on the
bubble there let's see how it goes
but as a republican I gotta say this is
a rising star in your party
[Applause]
I'm doing this in a long time
okay all right so first question is for
you what's the role of government in
policing big tech oh well that opens up
a can of worms well you write about that
in your book a lot you're all over that
yeah that's well that's something people
on both sides can agree about I think to
a degree 100 yeah big Tech is stupid how
much power two and two little privacy so
what is the role of government to police
them where are we I mean we often talk
here about this thing is it is it more
like the post office is there more like
the utility company it's a newspaper
what is it a little bit more like a
utility and you know this is not typical
of a republican approach to things but I
don't think the antitrust laws are
sufficient to deal with this problem
because as you say it's not just Market
power it's privacy and
the control of speech censorship and I
think Congress is going to have to
intervene and pass a statute that's
targeted at those problems and what do
they and what's in the bill I mean what
a that's where I mean the problem comes
in is like everybody thinks there needs
to do something to be done but
how do you I think they have to scale
Americans are usually for you know
giving private companies free reign uh
personally I think they have to except
in certain areas we've regulated media
cable companies networks telephones and
they're all for that there are certain
times where it's required it's necessary
yeah and and what I think we should do
here is skinny down these companies by
requiring them to divest some of the
companies that they've acquired that
could be competitors so Facebook would
have to give up Instagram
uh Google would have to give up
YouTube
I like a little Pat there
just let me know here it's coming uh
well I saw in the news that Facebook and
Instagram are now going to allow you to
show a bare breast but only if it's of a
gender or a non-binary person I can't
make this up
no I'm not even yeah right okay and and
then my only thought is to ask Congress
to be weighing in on this thing you've
got members of Congress I'm not all I'm
I'm a cut techie myself but that don't
even know how to log into Zoom or to log
into Facebook that'll be making the
rules for these things you know they
don't understand the technology
sometimes or whatever okay this is for
you Trump will make his first 2024
campaign appearance oh in your home
state of South Carolina
did you know this I will not be there
but will you you will not be I will not
be there
I got I got something else going on that
day
I don't know what it is you don't even
know what day it is
going on no I you know my thing is I
hope there's a a big deep wide bench in
2024 I want to see a vigorous primary I
plan on hosting a bunch of candidate
forums we're going to call it cocktails
with the candidates for 2024. uh I want
to see a woman on the ticket I want to
see a little more diversity on our side
it's been a hundred years since women
got the right to vote where are our
Republican women and they need to run
for president
well
I mean I guess that's my cutest thing is
that a declaration
yeah you know I've got I have two
constituents actually Tim Scott Nikki
Haley who who the media they both live
in the first congressional district we
run for president it's exciting to see
that in South Carolina but the last time
anyone from the U.S House ran for
president that was Abraham Lincoln and I
have no Abe Lincoln I won't be running
uh for that anytime soon but uh but we
have some exciting things happening in
South Carolina great leaders but you
could definitely be on the ticket I mean
I mean like if Ron DeSantis said hey I I
might spontaneously first person
yeah yeah you should see me in church
yeah
well that's that's not going to happen
Okay um
[Applause]
didn't on the card was will you endorse
Trump if he's the Republican that's
always the question when you have
Republicans on here right well I mean
this is just somebody wrote this I
didn't write this every time I'm just
I'm just a I'm just a monkey
no no that's what overtime is these are
these are the people the people want to
know this uh yeah I mean it's see it's
so tough for you I I get why this it's
not it's actually it's not tough I mean
I I would love to see a a Big Field I
want to see a diversity of opinions I
have my own opinions on where the future
of the country is we need a unifier we
need someone who's going to bring in not
just Republicans and conservatives
independent voters and that's not the
question
I'm getting there but independent voters
want a home and um if it's between Biden
and anybody else and with anybody else
end of the day
including Trump
that's where he is I mean I never would
have thought Joe Biden was that scary I
mean we were just talking before the
show ended about stuff that we're not
crazy about with Joe Biden and he
certainly has not stuck the landing on
all of it
but the fact that he Joe Biden who not
that long ago was just seen as a kind of
a Clubby politician who everybody could
get along with he wasn't crazy out there
in any way that he is that much of a
Dracula to you guys that you would go
for Donald Trump for Donald Trump who we
already saw is not just stupid but crazy
he's somehow both
and you're okay with that
you talked about the dead singer Biden
won't even talk to Republicans about
budget reform right now I'm gonna have
this debt ceiling vote without any
budget reform that should be a
bipartisan yeah that guy was writing
Love Letters to the Korean dude I mean
it's not it's apples and oranges you're
talking about normal and I'm saying but
this is outside of normal and you've
seen it it's not like it's new or he's
gonna change when he gets in office
we've had one term this is 2023 it's not
2017.
it's it's a non-starter for me I mean
any party that nominates that man is not
a party that should be in any sort of
government position
so
so my thought is how do you because I
don't think I I don't think the left is
capable of really taking on Trump so so
how do we how do we find someone in the
Republican ranks to replace Trump we do
have some on the Sanders who you know
you could say all sorts of pluses and
minuses but if you want to get rid of
trump you need to you better place your
bets on him uh which is why I was
surprised that you said you would
combust if he asked you to be his vice
president
things but we haven't had a member of
the U.S house go into the White House as
as president vice president since
Abraham Lincoln I mean it just doesn't
happen I am I'm happy with the president
of a variety I love my job but I'm not
happy with an insane
vengeful pathological crazy person right
like Trump and we've already seen it
already happened he already tried it he
already tried the coup the thing that is
the safe word for you guys he already
tried it again we've seen it and I know
you can't say anything because when
you're in the party if you go across
that line then somehow you're toxic so I
already crossed that line she primaried
man Republicans to survive a primary
we'll move on all right Andrew the bill
was Bill was about to say something in a
nutshell I think when the parties are
relatively close together or in the same
ballpark or in the same universe right
character should count for much more
than it does these days and it's much
easier to compromise and I think the
dynamic that's governing here is that
when you have a group that's way out to
the left talking about fundamentally
transforming the United States and so
forth It's hard to get compromised
because people think they're making it
it's a slippery slope and they're
dealing with potential Armageddon and
that's also why they say look if it
comes between policy and character on
this case I'll go with policy I mean I
think it's I I look I mean we you and I
Andrew we both talk of you write about
it I talk about it I hear on your
podcast
um it's there is something going on that
is very
cultural revolution in China 1966 with
the red guards on the left there just is
the fear is that Biden is not in control
of that it's in control of him right
right and and he doesn't even kind of
realize what is what is going on that's
my sense anyway I like Joe Biden but how
can you know how do you dislike German I
mean you know but also it's a that I
mean people in an indivisible hands he's
okay
it's a bit off as much as we as much as
here we go like it's not just weird not
too long and as much as we acknowledge
that that is happening on the left it is
a slow and encroaching problem whereas
Trump seems to be sort of immediate and
existential but let me ask the last
question today Andrew what should
Republicans and Democrats be doing
differently to appeal to Millennials and
gen Z
um I think the Democrats will stop
trying to Pander to them so much because
I think that suggests the party doesn't
have its own ideas about the world
um or that kids like being pandered to
no the the the the they they they can be
grown-ups if you tell them that what you
want to do and they'll agree with
disagree with you but tell them it's not
cool they can they're one thing they are
good at they're media Savvy and they can
smell pandering yeah when you do it in
advertising they hate it yeah when they
can spell that out and I think they can
smell that out and as you said earlier
in the show they want to be led they
want somebody to they know their kids
you know when I was a kid I didn't want
to be like kids I wanted to be like
Johnny Carson and James Bond
you know grown ass man I don't know why
I will look up here
yeah no I I get that so what do they do
so what do the parties do well I think
the main problem that the Republicans
have apart from Trump I think is is the
successful branding of them by the
Democrats as racist homophobic all the
things that the younger generation is
just over right uh and they don't have
they they haven't been able to spend
this in a message of saying
we believe that you should succeed in
America
regardless of your background or
orientation or or race or color or Creed
as opposed to the Democrats saying we
want you to succeed because
right so the that's the way you want to
contrast
we want to diverse Multicultural
multi-racial future based upon
individual rights individual Freedom uh
free speech and and the chaos of
American culture let's let's go America
they're too scared right now and they've
been I think psyched out in thinking
that they can't embrace the cause of
diversity it's just a different kind of
diversity they need to embrace yes
any thoughts on that for your party and
uh the younger generation that doesn't
seem to be too in love with you we got
to stop acting like Alpha hotels I mean
you know when Rove B Wade was overturned
we just turned our backs on women across
the country and that's an issue I was
raped at the age of 16. and
something I've been very passionate
about I'm pro-life but I also see that
we gotta find middle ground with America
about 89 of people are in the middle and
we've got to protect women's rights and
the right to life and there's a way to
work together on many of these issues
cannabis is another one I don't know it
was but cannabis is another issue I I
have a bill called the states Reform Act
uh that that that takes that issue and
makes it in a way that's bipartisan that
Republicans and Democrats can get on
Republicans have been the wrong side of
cannabis we've been on the wrong side of
Roe v Wade we in birth control and gay
marriage and all these issues that are
important environmental issues what
should the law be for Road Rovers and
now that it's turned back to this really
I mean we could write a law now which is
what most other countries do am I right
I think most European countries have
laws which are very often to the right
of where we're looking for them
and we're talking about
Germany or Denmark yeah pretty liberal
countries but now that we could and
probably will write a law about it what
should that law say because when you say
we can kind of split the difference
that's a hard thing to do it's very hard
yeah but it is what does the law say
that it's abortion is legal but only
until 12 weeks or 15 weeks or whatever
well I think gestational limits should
be part of that conversation in Europe
it's if you're even allowed to have one
it's 12 to 15 weeks on average that
would be where you you would well I mean
Democrats Democrats are at 24
Republicans are in Congress probably at
15. you know can you get to 20 and meet
in the middle but both sides have to be
willing to put some abortion legal right
well especially exceptions for rape
incest like the mother fetal
abnormalities uh those kinds of things
but before we even get there we can't
even pass legislation right now in
Congress to give Every Woman access to
birth control we can't even do that and
if you can't even do that that's that
saves lives that that fewer pregnancies
mean fewer wants and needs to have
abortions we have entire counties in
South Carolina where we don't have a
single OB GYN doctor I mean and so like
let's start there let's start with birth
control making sure every woman has
access it is a republican point of view
you can support
yes yes you can yeah I let the states
make the rules and uh regarding these
things I'm perfectly happy if they do I
think the federal government needs to
stay out of this stuff I never
understood that that something could be
so high up on the moral totem pole as
life or not life and then but let the
states do it because North Carolina
wants to kill babies that's certainly
fine in North Carolina but in South
Carolina We Believe babies right
I know but either it is or it isn't I
mean how can it be up to this how can
how could you cross the line of one
state to another and have something so
fundamental change it seems silly yeah
well that's what we are well there are a
couple of different you know what do
people personally believe what do I
think is a conservative is a solution
that'll keep us a stable a durable
solution that will uh be a stable
solution in this country it has to
conform politics is not about affirming
truth it's about finding a compromise
between different opinions right that's
only is going to mean on some of these
questions like abortion you're going to
have to live in a country which is
violating other people violating some
core feelings and beliefs of yours so
get used to it learn to live with it
accept it you know I I I'm I you know I
actually I I believe the the the fetus
is a human life
uh but I do understand that it's inside
someone else's body
I do understand I don't like governments
telling people what to do inside their
body I also believe there are good faith
disagreements good faith disagreements
about when a human life becomes a human
person and so we have to accept that
that'll be a problem the one thing I
would say add to this discussion is is
uh and I'm the last person to talk about
this I will never have anything to do
with an abortion but is is the one
exception I would meet is late term
abortions which are often used as a
cultural in this in this war and they
say yo you want thirsty well this is
Barbara you know
I think you make an exemption for women
who find out very late in pregnancy that
their baby or their child is incredible
has terrible uh deformative or
developmental issues or is gonna live
like a few minutes or right and the
question is simply how do we humanely
allow this child to die and and to come
and that that is I mean for the women
involved it's usually just horrifying
and the families is awful and to come in
there and condemn people for making
those decisions I don't want to do that
great okay thank you very much everybody
off to a new start